le spectacle commence en coulisses
[Musique]
deux cas de dengue dont la reprise
passait en cinquantaine de danseurs
comédiens musiciens et chanteurs à
maquiller à habiller à chacun son
histoire
j'avais l'âge de 3 ans car j'ai eu le
diagnostic de deux lotissements
on avait dit aux parents de tara
bouchant qu'elle ne parlerait jamais
première fois que je chante avec l'opéra
de montréal ces malades
[Musique]
quand il ya du public
j'en donne plus pour le public
on est les plus expérimentés de la game
on est aussi des plus nerveux
[Musique]
oh
présenté à l'opéra de bizet devient une
histoire d'intimidation bien actuelle
dans l'ombre il ya le travail des
artistes de la gagne à rendre où
l'organisme qui amènent des personnes
déficientes intellectuelles et autistes
à vivre les arts de la scène
[Musique]
à la fin il reste le sentiment d'avoir
assisté à un spectacle unique
j'ai été touché par la tempête et puis
- là le vrai ça c'est un travail où les
gens c'est un don de soi ils comptent
pas leurs heures pour ces pratiques là
une chose m'a beaucoup touché c'est la
présence de soliste et leurs rapports
avec avec les gens qui vivent avec une
déficience intellectuelle mais qui sont
des acteurs des chanteurs
ainsi anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal
[Musique]